foreign
Paul's in New York City hi Paul welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi Dave and John thanks for taking my
call
um I just finished I just finished The
Total Money Makeover and um my rent's
over 50 of my take-home pay
um I'm a single dad that just went
through a really long and expensive
divorce and I'm just trying to figure
out how to get my situation under
control wow sorry
that's horrible well I mean can we agree
that 50 of your take-home pay
is not mathematically sustainable
yes absolutely and and the hard part is
uh I so I have a two bedroom apartment
uh so that my son has space and
um my rent is relatively affordable for
Brooklyn yeah unfortunately yeah I don't
doubt that I mean you live in one of the
most expensive real estate markets in
the world
yeah so that I don't doubt that but
obviously you don't make enough money to
live there
yeah
so one of the two things if you want to
have a sustainable life and not end up
with you know substantial Financial
damage to your life
or you struggle and have stress you're
going to either increase your income
in the next months or even year
um dramatically or you're going to move
well the uh the situation becomes uh
even more complicated when so I have
split custody of my son and in our
agreement
um the his his school is already set to
stay in Brooklyn
um
for the next
four years and then we would have to
work out where High School is which
would most likely stay in the city and
I'm already I live in a neighborhood
where his school is and I already
commute an hour into my job in Manhattan
was your divorce
um
was it amicable to just sit down and
shake hands or was it a mess
it was a mess okay
um
what do you do for a living
I'm a photographer
you're going to change careers or you're
going to move yeah
yeah because dude I mean regardless of
the constraints that you and your
ex-wife and the courts have put on you
none of you get a pass on math because
we decided these things math is still
going to kick your butt
yeah and I I would love to just wave a
wand and make this all okay I don't but
my magic wands low on batteries
so something is going to change and
you're either going to change it or it's
going to be changed for you
because this is not sustainable
bad things are going to happen and force
you
out of this situation
and um you're just not able to be there
it's that simple or good things are
going to happen and you find different
housing a different housing Arrangement
you find uh and more income to be able
to sustain this but it's just it's not
like a Dave ruin it's not like oh here's
the best thing you can do this is you
know you simply cannot survive doing
this long term I mean you can survive
for a few months or maybe a year but
you've got to have a plan to develop a
life
that that works and this doesn't work
this is going to lead to homelessness
and
that's at the end of this line this just
becomes a mess is because you've created
a an unsustainable you've created a very
anxious life
I'm just thinking about this little boy
that comes home and half of his life
comes home to a exhausted stressed out
dad who's trying to figure out how to
give his kid this magical life like you
mentioned it's got this that math
doesn't apply to that can barely afford
rent they can barely afford groceries
and that's a kid constantly coming home
to a tense home to an anxious home
and that means we gotta we got to change
that whole thing because it is this
whole thing's going to end in Ash but
you're also going to end with a frazzled
exhausted kid who feels responsible for
making sure dad's okay and that's not
your kid's job and so man I I think now
you're gonna start looking to take
pictures in the evenings and on weekends
and at Big Wedding events and you're
gonna have to find yourself a job where
you're gonna make way more money yeah
something's going to give
so um I I always suggest if we're going
to have pain let's choose the pain
instead of letting it choose us yes
every time and there's 100 of the
situation that's going to have pain
so choose the pain the pain is a career
change an adjustment to what type of
Photography you do or when you do it the
pain is moving the pain is a different
housing situation within the constraints
of the neighborhood which is probably
very difficult but there's something is
going to give you can't just sit here
and go in the name of all that is noble
and good for my child I'm going to
pretend like this isn't happening
because it's going to happen to you
you cannot sustain the situation
um it's just that simple and it's a it's
not me that's just 30 years of coaching
people and counseling people that are in
trouble and dude you're trouble looking
for a place to happen right now and
let's let's we talked about this in an
earlier segment let's don't forget you
have the opportunity to teach your son
over at one to two to three to four year
period
what it looks like to change Midstream
to get that grit and resilience we were
talking about that earlier segment to
develop new skills and new strength and
see his dad go back to school and see
his dad get qualified for new jobs he is
dead do all these really hard gritty
things
for his son and for the sake of his
family tree moving forward
it's not going to be pleasant at the
time but man you're giving your kid a
gift yeah you've got to get this
situation healthy because I will give
you
unless your ex-wife is an anomaly
she's also facing the same thing you're
facing
unless she's like you know uh a heart
surgeon or something and and you know uh
in in Manhattan you know making 500k
she's probably also facing the same
thing
so if she could be an anomaly but if
she's trying to do it could be you all
had two average to below average
incomes when combined made it work in
the city
but split up both of you are screwed
that may be where you are and so your
kid may be going from one stressed house
to another stressed house to John's
Point likely is I don't know I don't
know your ex's situation but uh and I'm
not going to get into that that doesn't
matter but I'm just saying there's a
high probability that's going on too so
she's she doesn't get a pass on math
just because she's pissed at you either
math catches up with you it works in New
York it works in California it works in
Abilene Works in Tulsa and it works in
Nashville and it always works the same
because it's math
and you just cannot run from it uh and
it's not a Dave thing it's not a Ramsay
thing it's not a hateful thing it's not
a racist thing it's just math when we
live in a in a culture that says follow
your passion and follow your dreams well
my dream is to be a photographer in
Manhattan like I'm going to go to the
epicenter of all that is fashion and all
that is high society and I'm going to be
a photographer I'm going to capture and
be an artist
and then all of a sudden you get
divorced and rent doesn't care what your
dreams are
rent just cares what the dollar amount
is yeah I'm sorry I'm heartbroken for
you man I'm sorry you're facing this
it's hard and I'm not belittling
uh how painful this is I'm just begging
you to choose your pain because of all
the other pain you've been through and
in the name of creating a fantasy land
for your child sometimes people don't
choose the pain and it will choose you
if you don't choose it
so pick your poison
what's it going to be
something's going to move and I strongly
suggest to you my friend that you do the
moving instead of the moving being done
on you
because not acting is going to bring
this to your doorstep